[Music]
I've been here 50 years ago as a postdoc
was my first experience out of my own
country so it was I don't want to call
it a shock but something very very
exciting and what does it mean it means
good to come back at that time it wasn't
even Carnegie Mellon well it was just
mellowed and within that here it it was
they unified so now I'm getting there
they weren't overly degree from a place
that I was in a place that became where
I was very exciting right everything was
new for me although I already had a PhD
life all the time now science thinks
well different and they challenging very
very challenging I think that I learned
a lot I have one advice just one advice
you want to hear it
don't look for advices do what you feel
is good for you that you can contribute
that you can find yourself that you can
end that you love don't you for other
people's no not always something to
repeat